hi there take a look at these faces try
to decide which of these faces are
criminals and which ones are law-abiding
citizens I'll give you a second okay got
it
so if you decided that these four here
are the criminals you would be correct
and that makes these three the
law-abiding citizens as for this one
maybe if the crime is being too cool of
course none of these faces actually
exists in real life these are
compositions of eigenfaces of datasets
of criminals and non criminals today's
paper is a absolute controversy this is
going to get me into so much trouble so
if you see something like this in the
news always always always go and check
now we're going to look at automated
inference on criminality using face
images by shouting woo and G Cheung on
high level they're trying to separate
criminals from non criminals using face
images so basically using classifiers on
ID photos this of course has has
generated quite the uproar
I suggest we just dive into the paper
and look at what's happening right here
we study for the first time automated
inference on criminality based solely on
still face images which is free of any
biases and subjective judgments of human
observers right so they say we train a
bunch of models including as you can see
a CNN using facial images of 1856 real
persons controlled for race gender age
and facial expressions
nearly half of whom were convicted
criminals force criminais ting between
criminals and non criminals so this is
the outset this is the kind of research
question here now immediately you have
people jumping up saying that's not
possible and I would agree but I think
actually there are
very very interesting lessons to be
learned from this paper so they're
saying they they actually managed to do
this with their classifiers actually
with all of these classifiers of course
deep learning being the best also some
discriminating structural features for
predicting criminality have been found
by machine learning so they even tell
you why above all the most important
discovery of this research is that
criminal and non-criminal face images
populate two quite distinctive manifolds
the variation among criminal faces is
significantly greater than that of non
criminal faces the two manifolds
consisting of criminal and non-criminal
faces appear to be concentric with the
non criminal manifold lying in the
kernel with the smaller span exhibiting
a law of normality for faces of non
criminals oh I'm gonna be canceled I
don't advocate for it this is not this
is not this I'm not a fan of this just
in other words the faces of general
law-abiding public have a greater degree
of resemblance compared with the faces
of criminals or criminals have a higher
degree of dissimilarity in facial
appearance than non criminals so
basically what they're saying is that
the this kind of similarity among the
non criminals in their dataset is larger
than the singularity among the criminals
okay
so already the outset right then they go
into this introduction and in the
introduction we won't go in through
fully but they basically introduced the
concept of facial recognition they try
to build up kind of an argument
where they say faces are different some
people have hypothesized that it's
possible to infer personality traits
from face facial features some studies
exist that show that people agree on the
perception of these traits so not the
actual traits but people will kind of
agree that a face looks
extroverted or more agreeable people
tend to agree that the appearance exists
and then they sort of make the next step
and say okay can facial features also be
used not just for predicting the
appearance but to predict the actual
personality trait for validating the
hypothesis on the correlations between
the innate traits and social behaviors
of a person and the physical
characteristics of that person's face it
would be hard push to find a more
convincing experiment than examining the
success rate of discriminating between
criminals and non criminals so actually
you could agree with this right since
this is sort of a distinction one can
make about behavior whether or not
someone breaks the law or in this case
is caught and convicted and so on there
are like many many hurdles in this in
essence the statement sort of makes
sense like if you could actually do this
from facial features that would be very
first of all very surprising and second
of all very drastic people immediately
jump to the conclusion that okay if such
a thing were found that means you could
somehow pre cognate criminality which I
don't think it has to be because what
could also be the case is they have a
they have a quote from Aristotle right
here
it is possible to infer character from
features if it is granted that body and
soul are changed together by the natural
affections one interpretation of me is
that let's say you break the law for
whatever it could be completely moral
like you steal the medicine for under
the old lady in your house and but you
know you broke the law you know you did
something that society doesn't want you
to do and that will exert stress on you
right you do now have to lie to people
about this you now have to sort of make
sure you're not caught you have to worry
maybe there's a security tape or
something like this and the stress will
we know that stress will physically
change you
and that could be in turn made out by
your features for example the stress of
being in jail could change your physical
features and since these are all
convicted criminals one might think that
it might be possible it might again not
saying it is it might so if you if we
throw away all of the kind of pre
judgments on this it could be an
interesting research question right
could now whether we want to pursue it
or not that's it a different question
but the way they build this up here is
that they only have the best of
intentions in mind I feel like this
might not be the case so they say
something like this right here at the
onset of this study our gut feeling is
that modern tools of machine learning
and computer vision will refute the
validity of physiognomy
although the outcomes turn out otherwise
this and this is the part where I just
stopped believing them that their
intentions were like all good and it's
just about disproving this so we can
just lay it to rest because they then is
very quickly switched when they find
something else non criminals are the
normals and the criminals are like the
that just rubs me the wrong way where
you'll have to say me it's like the Ku
Klux Klan going like oh no we you know
we have many social gatherings and our
gut feeling is that people aren't really
different and the robes are actually
personal protective equipment it's all
actually just a community you think we
all you know good intentions on every
now and then we lent you guys going into
this with sort of a mixed bag of
feelings where you'd have a
hypothetically valid research question
but also even the introduction makes it
very clear because it's someone over the
top promising to just be neutral and be
good good intended not gonna fall for it
sorry they say in order to conduct their
experiments they have 1856 ID photos the
following criteria Chinese male between
ages of 18 and 55 no facial hair no
facial scars or other markings
the dataset is called yes then there's
two subsets sn4 non-criminals and SC for
criminals
the non-criminals contains ID photos of
alone 126 non criminals that were
acquired from the internet using the web
spider tool they're from a wide gamut of
professions and social status including
waiters construction will bubble okay
the subset of the criminals contains ID
photos of 730 criminals of which 330 as
are published as wanted suspects by the
Ministry of Public Security of China and
by the departments of Public Security
for the provinces of Wang dong Jung
soo-jung Ling etc the others are
provided by City Police Department in
China under confidentiality agreement we
stress and here here's an important
point we stress that the criminal phase
images in SCR normal ID photos not
police mug shots so they say they have
violent crimes or non violent crimes and
so on so they have these examples here
of those images so the top ones are the
criminals and the bottom ones are the
non criminals now people immediately see
differences here and if you spotted that
all of these have white colors and none
of those have white colors then you
would be correct
now you're on the right path you're not
actually correct correct but you're on
the right path here because actually
what they do is they mask away the
colors so they only extract the face
part and the upper neck part so these
this white collar part will actually not
be on the image that they analyze to
control for clothing which is good but
it gives you sort of an indication that
the origins of the
to image groups might not actually be
you know the same so what you'll have is
you'll have basically a database
actually have two databases of criminals
which are so the one database is this
wanted let's call them W these are
released by the police for wanted
criminals then the others database is
the convicted criminals let's call that
C and then on the other side you have
the database of non criminals and the
non criminals come from the internet so
you have three different databases and
of course these two make will going to
make up the criminals and this will make
up the non criminals and the herein lies
the problem right you even though the
white colors are masked out you have to
make sure that whatever you find isn't
just a property of how you collected the
data and this doesn't really come
through in this paper so they they do
data preparation as again they mask
their resize and so on and I stress
again all our ID images with frontal
lighting so yeah and they okay so now
they test the classifiers so they say we
test logistic regression logistic
regression KNN SVM and CNN on the image
data set so for the CNN you can just
input the original image but for the
other classifiers you need a set of
features and what they do is they
concatenate three different image
feature vectors so the first one is
facial landmark points that you extract
by some sort of tool you can extract
whatever corners of mouth and so on then
the second facial facial feature vector
generated by a modular PCA and the
third is the facial feature vector based
on a local local binary pattern
histograms so these are these are sort
of face features that people use for
recognizing faces they concatenate them
that gives you a feature vector you feed
that into the machine learning algorithm
and they do a we perform a 10-fold
cross-validation for all possible
combinations of three feature different
classifiers and the four types of
feature vectors plus a date to driven
CNN so they do a 10-fold
cross-validation right which basically
means you you do you partition your data
into ten parts you take nine to Train
predict the one then you take the next
nine to train predict the one that you
left out and so on this kind of you get
a train test split across all sorts of
splits of your data which is a it's a
you know it's a valid thing to do and
they discover here that there CNN
classifier performs at almost 90 percent
accuracy as you can see here and even
their SVM and the other classifiers it
performed fairly well in recognizing
these criminality faces so and they
analyzed you know the the ROC curves and
the ROC curves this this is a really
this is a class her that works right so
you can see even the the the other
models but especially the CNN classifier
here works really well of course the
question is what does it work for so
they basically say alright we now have a
classifier that distinguishes criminals
from non criminals and I would say you
have a classifier that descriptors
discriminate your particular pictures of
criminals from your particular pictures
of non criminals and if this were
submitted to me as a reviewer I would
expect that any sane author would then
go and try to invalidate that so here's
what you'll have to do if you want to
convince me that this is not just due to
how you collected your data you need to
go
and you need to basically say okay I
have these different methods of
collecting data right here now maybe I
can go to the police and ask them for a
picture from the same database of a non
convicted knotless of a non criminal
someone that was arrested but then not
convicted and I can you know have
someone from from here that I can put in
that data set and then you have to show
me that your classifier will correctly
predict that that's a non criminal and
if it predicts it's a criminal it's due
to the data set and you can also find
one of the criminals but find their
picture on the internet like you collect
the non criminals and that will give you
someone from this database in that data
set and then you have to show me that
your classifier correctly predicts
that's a criminal you can further
convince me that your classifier is
neutral to this separation right here of
the wanted and convicted criminals
because they all should be criminals
right so if your classifier is neutral
to that then it basically doesn't care
where it comes from so this would be a
weaker argument but still one that one
could investigate what do they do
for validating their method here is
where it gets funky so they say given
the high social sensitivities and
repercussions of our topic and skeptics
on physiognomy we try to exercise
maximum caution before publishing our
results yeah you failed in playing
devil's advocate we design and conduct
the following experiments to challenge
the validity of the tested classifiers
for the task of discriminating between
criminals and non criminals all right
this is it right here here is where you
give us where you tell us it's not
because of how we collected the data
which is the obvious explanation
we randomly label the faces in the very
sample set s as negative and positive
instances with equal probability and
redo all the above experiments of binary
classification well how can it is this
all right they're basically saying well
if our classifier were not a criminality
classifier that means we could
invalidate it by shuffling the labels
and if that comes out to 50/50 then our
classifier obviously works because it's
not 50/50 in this data set so basically
they're great they're just validating
that a classification algorithm can
classify something right The Critic
criticism here is never that they
haven't actually trained a working
classifier the criticism is what have
they train the classifier for but they
their entire validation procedure is
basically we don't have a bug in our
cohort oh the outcomes show that the
randomly generated negative and positive
instances cannot be distinguished at all
gee who guessed a classifier on random
labels doesn't generalize man in fact in
fact we go much further along the self
critical path all right here it comes
here it comes
and carry out the same experiments for
random labeling on different samples of
the same size and with the same variable
control
only this time in the selection criteria
are standard any photos of Chinese
female young middle-aged or standard any
photos of Caucasian male young
middle-aged
of Caucasian female young middle-aged no
facial so basically if you train on a
randomly labeled data set on any day
okay these sort of pictures your
classifier with a lot work thanks thanks
maybe that's a I think that's the
academically most valid statement in the
entire paper oh man in none of the three
cases any of the four clusters managed
to achieve a true positive rate higher
than fifty three percent on randomly
labeled positive and negative instances
so the classifier must be valid because
okay the above experiments rule out that
the good accuracies of the four
evaluated classifiers in phase inference
on criminality are due to data
overfitting no otherwise given the same
sample size they would also be able to
distinguish between randomly labeled
positive and negative instances with
significantly better chances than k but
they did cross-validation the they did
the cross-validation prevents the
overfitting
we know one criticizes that you owe
these people have no idea what they're
doing they have no clue of machine
learning they don't know what the
problems with methods are the they don't
know what overfitting is and and how you
control for it
the big jump of the true positive rate
from random labeling to truth labeling
onto the same set of face image can only
be explained by intrinsic separable 'ti
of s c and s n that is true that is true
but why are they separable that's the
question ok as different source cameras
generated the ID photos in the set s now
that then it might be on the right track
here different source cameras may be
they get the idea that different data
sources lead to different things they
might leave their signatures that
although below perception threshold in
signal strength could mislead machine
learning okay so they're basically
saying different cameras can generate
different sort of artifacts and they
rule this out by basically adding noise
to the images such that these artifacts
would be washed out and that the noise
doesn't change their results gee there
was so close they were so close to
actually doing something useful okay
this section is where it gets even more
interesting now they're trying to guess
from their classifier what are the
actual features that make criminals
criminals so discriminating features
right here having obtained the above
strong empirical evidences for the
validity of automated face induced
inference on criminality one cannot
resist the following intriguing
questions what features of a human face
betray its owner's propensity for crimes
um okay Shakespeare um and they
basically they basically go and explain
ability route where they see were what
the classifier pays attention to and it
turns out a classifier pays attention to
the following feature so on the left you
can see where the classifier pays
attention to no surprise here
it pays attention to face features but
they kind of parse out the following
three features first of all the d the
distance between the eyes in criminals
tends to be smaller than in non
criminals the angle between the nose and
the corners of the mouth tends to be
smaller in criminals than in non
criminals and the curvature of the upper
lip can
to be higher in criminals than in non
criminals so let's let's try just from
this information to draw the ultimate
criminal and non-criminal faces so first
of all the non criminal let's draw the
non criminal as just regular I'm not
very good at this so here's the nose and
then let's just draw the lips like this
non criminal perfect looks like a
law-abiding citizen to me criminal right
here so the eyes are closer together
here's the nose and then the curvature
of the upper lip is higher so hmm and
then the angle between the nose and the
outer corners of the mouth is smaller
how can I make the angle smaller could
it be that if I oh yes ah that's the
trick criminal
ladies and gentlemen so are you telling
me that all someone has to do to be a
criminal is frown yeah totally valid so
they're so close right but they say all
these are intrinsic facial features but
come on alright so they go they go on to
say that they they have some Easter gram
differences of these features that they
basically say these features are what's
responsible for this and then they do
face clustering which is beautiful so
first of all what they do is they sort
of take the average faces for criminals
and non criminals and these are the
average faces so the top are the actual
average eigenfaces and the bottom is
when you can
shift the facial landmarks around the
seeming paradox that SC and SN can be
classified but the average faces appear
almost the same can sorry the average
faces appear almost the same
the average faces appear almost the same
what a paradox these are almost the same
I mean if I just overlay them one over
another they're almost the same
there is no no difference at all I don't
see a difference how what could possibly
be the difference what what could be the
difference I don't think that these are
the most honest of intentions so they
basically do some clustering which I
find interesting I find interesting for
example that they don't really explain I
so map here so I so map uses the
geodesic distance between two points on
the manifold which is defined between
the sum of the weights but we will do it
all right so the kind of washee-washee
I so map but they then explain k-means
in great detail with formulas and again
these I mean okay not machine learning
people can do machine learning that's
fine but they're not really into the
matter here and they try k-means
clustering and they find in their
opinion they find for clusters of
criminals and three clusters of non
criminals now why three and four and
usually can do something like this by
clustering and then measuring the
residual variance in your data so how
much does one cluster explain two
clusters and so on so here you can see
the curves for non criminals and
criminals now they claim that the
optimal number of clusters here for non
criminals is three which makes no sense
to me like why three what you usually
want to find is kind of a kink in your
curve like if it's steep and then it
gets flat that means that up until then
your clusters actually buy you something
good and from then they basically are
you
so if I were to guess I would divide the
criminals into two clusters and the non
criminals into a single cluster because
that's pretty flat
certainly not the crit non-criminals
into three and the criminals into four
that makes no sense at all like why and
they say okay these are the clusters
right here and these are the pictures
I've shown you at the beginning what
surprised the bottom ones the non
criminals are smiling and the top ones
aren't gee I wonder why the method works
and the interesting part here is that
we're how can we justify maybe how can
we say if we decide on one cluster for
non criminals and two clusters for
criminals what does that remind us of oh
yes that is exactly how we collected the
data that is exactly the fact that we
collected the non criminals with one
procedure and the criminals with two
different procedures gee they're
classified their dataset replicates
exactly how they collected the data and
that convinces me that it says
absolutely nothing about the actual
criminality of people it's just that
police even if it's ID photos they they
don't smile and pictures on the Internet
sometimes people smile the rest of the
paper is pretty much garbage they did
reply to critics and they kind of take
issue with a number of things so first
name-calling
I don't mean to name-call but it's going
to happen I don't get why people call
them racist because it's always say
doesn't know I'm no trouble and smiley
ah in our experiments we did control
facial expressions but not faint micro
Express
the critique that our methods can be
reduced to a simple discriminator of
smiling versus not smiling has given us
a new angle of scrutiny they say what
Westerners think that this is smiling
but our Chinese students and colleagues
even after being prompted to consider
the cue of smile failed to detect the
same so basically their answer is yeah
you think so but we don't and then they
say instead they only find the faces in
the bottom row appearing somewhat more
relaxed than those in the top row hmm
and then here's the crucial part all
criminal ID photos are government issues
but not mug shots they are normal
government issue ID portraits like those
- driver license in the USA in contrast
most of the non criminal ID style photos
are taken officially by some
organizations such as real estate
companies law firms etc for their
website
you know what I'd always says when you
take your picture for a government ID
please don't smile imagine if you're a
law firm comes to you and say we want a
picture for a website please don't smile
all right this was it for this paper if
you like this content please consider
subscribing and sharing it out this is
absolute garbage and if there is
important lessons to learn here namely
Occam's razor is a real problem in
research people often fail to criticize
themselves enough and to think is there
maybe a different explanation for why
I'm getting the results that I'm getting
and how can I disprove that that is the
case and how can I make sure that the
effect that I'm seeing actually comes
from the place where I claim it comes
from I think this is a real threat
throughout all of research I've seen
many papers that I've reviewed that are
exactly of the same fallacy not as
touchy subjects as this one but it
definitely exists and I remind everyone
that learn a lesson from this and have a
good day